[Music]
foreign
and a very Merry Christmas welcome to
Sky News breakfast now the Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski has urged
his war-battered Nation to come together
and try to celebrate Christmas Even
though the holiday will have a bitter
taste he says this year for the first
time Ukraine's Orthodox Church is
allowing worshipers to congregate today
rather than on the 7th of January in a
widening shift from the Russian church
but of course many ukrainians will spend
a day in cold and darkness because of
Russian missile attacks on Power and
Water infrastructure president zielinski
joins religious leaders including the
archbitter bishop of Canterbury and the
Pope in using Christmas messages to
denounce the war
unfortunately this year all holidays
have a bitter taste for us and we can
feel the traditional spirits of
Christmas differently dinner at The
Family Table may not be so tasty and
warm there may be empty chairs around it
and our homes and streets may not be so
bright and Christmas bells may not sound
so loud and inspiring because of Air
Raid Sirens or even worse shots and
explosions and all this together can
pose a great threat this is despair in
higher forces and their power and
goodness and Justice in the world loss
of Hope Loss of Love loss of self
it's one of the Saba chowder is here
with more on a powerful message there
Saba from president zielinski yes good
morning Dumber absolutely in a rather
poignant message there to the people of
Ukraine president zielinski talks about
how different this Christmas will be for
the people of Ukraine this year he spoke
about how around the dinner table for
example uh certain loved ones will not
be there how food will taste different
he meant it in an emotional sense but
also actually in a physical sense as
well because the same access to food is
just not there that it was for example
say a year ago and also the fact that
this is all happening in the backdrop of
no heat of no water in certain cities
across the country and that's because of
a constant Russian attacks in terms of
missiles and drones now something that
is quite interesting is the timing of
this message and that's because
typically you ukrainians celebrate
Christmas on the 7th of January now this
is according to the Julian calendar
which is different to what we follow in
the west which is the Gregorian calendar
and um the reason why this is uh quite
interesting is because it's a separation
from the Russian Orthodox Church which
also like the ukrainians celebrates
typically Christmas on the 7th of
January but this year the Ukrainian
Orthodox church has said that it gives
people permission to celebrate Christmas
on the 25th if people so wish and the
reason for that again as I say is to
separate itself from how Russians do
things in a move closer to the West now
the leader of the Russian Orthodox
Church patriarch kiril he has previously
said that Russians that are killed in
the war will have their sins forgiven
and and cleared essentially uh by God
he's an avid supporter of Putin and of
course this is something that the
ukrainians are now saying we want to
separate ourselves from and tell us
about uh religious leaders and and their
message is also mentioning the war in
actually absolutely so um we've also
heard from Pope Francis he delivered an
address in the Vatican and Saint Peter's
Basilica to around 7 000 people in which
he spoke about the impact that things
like War have on children he talks about
the forgotten children and how when
certain injustices are carried out in
the world it's often young people who
are left behind and he also calls for
more empathy from the people we have a
clip here of him talking
this Christmas too as in the case of
Jesus a world ravenous for money power
and pleasure does not make room for the
little ones for so many unborn poor and
forgotten children I think above all of
the children devoured by War poverty and
Injustice yet those are the very places
to which Jesus comes a child in the
manger of rejection and refusal in him
the child of Bethlehem every child is
present and we ourselves are invited to
view life politics and history Through
The Eyes of children
so also talking about war is the
Archbishop of Canterbury uh Justin Welby
he talks about how in the UK and
generally speaking war is something that
affects everyone the world often forgets
Injustice but the person or being he
says that does not is God he says if God
forgets uh rather if the war forgets the
world forgets injustice God does not and
he also talks about some of the issues
that we Face domestically the cost of
living crisis people working in the
National Health Service those in
hospital beds and also there's a
touching tribute in there we will see
later at 11 o'clock to the queen this is
of course the country's first Christmas
without her which is indeed okay thank
you very much indeed Merry Christmas to
you Merry Christmas
now then also this morning a murder
investigation is underway after a woman
was shot and killed late on Christmas
Eve at a pub in a merseyside village she
died from her injuries in hospital after
the shooting at the Lighthouse Inn in
wallasey Village three men also suffered
gunshot wounds and a number of other
people are said to be injured police say
they believe the gunman left the pub car
park in a dark colored vehicle uh
possibly a Mercedes they say
okay let's take a look now at how
Christmas is being celebrated and has
been celebrated around the world
starting with the biblical town of
course of Bethlehem Mark in the
beginning of Christmas day with midnight
mass the church of nativity where the
mass was held sits on the spot where
Christians believe that Jesus was born
worship is gathered in the immaculate
Church near mosul in Iraq to celebrate
Christmas Eve Mass they crowded around a
bonfire in front of the church and sang
hymns inside karakosh is known as the
Christian capital of Iraq the the
Christian population has of course
dwindled considerably over the last
decades
well in Australia the faithful have
attended massive services including
Saint Mary's cathedral in Sydney and
Saint Paul's Cathedral in Melbourne but
many many others preferred of course to
be outdoors taking advantage of
Christmas in the summer Sydney's beaches
including Bondi being full of families
enjoying the sun's some of them
naturally in Santa hats
and from the White House a picture of
President Joe Biden the first lady
decorating their Christmas tree they
leave it late it was tweeted with the
caption just a few finishing touches
hope you and your loved ones are having
a great Christmas Eve
now the Duke and Duchess of Sussex have
responded to the controversial newspaper
column by Jeremy Clarks and dismissing
the sun's apology as nothing more than a
PR stunt in the column published last
week Jeremy Clarkson wrote that he hates
Megan on a cellular level and that he
dreams of her being shamed naked in the
street he tweeted his regret after the
column broke complaints records with the
independent press standards organization
ipso the sun issued an apology late
yesterday well in a statement released
in response a spokeswoman for the
sussexist said the fact that the sun has
not contacted the Duchess of Sussex to
apologize shows their intent this is
nothing more they say than a PR stunt a
true apology would be a shift in their
coverage and ethical standards for all
unfortunately we're not holding our
breath
staying with the royal family the king
will give his first Christmas Day
message later the second time he's
addressed the country after the death of
his mother the queen delivered every
televised Christmas speech since the
inaugural broadcast in 1957 so how about
her son's message differ well Sky's
Royal correspondent Rhiannon Mills looks
at what might be expected
[Music]
family like most of us have their
Christmas traditions the Princess of
Wales hosting a Carol service at
Westminster Abbey is quickly becoming
one of them but this year there will be
something distinctly different for all
of us
for 70 years it was the queen who spoke
to us all on Christmas Day always in her
own words often referring to her own
personal Christian faith now her son for
the first time will address the nation
and the Commonwealth
[Music]
in recent weeks he has already joined in
with the religious festivities with
visits celebrating diversity maybe
giving us a flavor of the kind of
message he'll want to get across funny
bits Archbishop and Galos will be
watching he's seen first hand on recent
engagements how he's settling in as king
the king's language of you know blessing
and Merry Christmas and appreciation for
the work of Christian communities and
Faith communities in the world and the
community at difficult times its own
indication that he's not shying away
from faith
and
you know I'm confident that we will
all be pleasantly satisfied
one thing that will be the same is the
Royals again heading to Sandringham with
the king and queen consort this time
playing host for a couple of years they
couldn't come here because of covid and
you can see why the queen would have
missed being here at Christmas but also
why the King has now decided that for
this festive period the family should be
back here in Norfolk after what has been
a difficult few months at times they can
completely get away from it all here
except on Christmas morning of course
when they open those gates for just a
couple of hours and let the crowds in so
I remember that Christmas morning so
well I knew coming up to me and saying
I've got this great photo you can see
from her photos and yes that one did
make all of the newspapers that Karen
Anvil is one of those dedicated locals
who turn up some as early as 5 a.m I
think it's going to be a
mixed emotions if I'm being not totally
honest with you I think people are
on board with the royal family
supportive of this new royal family
moving forwards as all coming together
it has been a diff difficult few years
for lots of reasons
um
but we're just so glad that there's
going to be normality do you know what I
mean they're back and we we want them
back
they're happy to lie to protect my
brother they were never willing to tell
the truth to protect us with this and
claims of racism as a Buckingham Palace
event the run-up to Christmas has seen
some serious questions for the
institution and for a king who more than
anything wants to show us what he's
really like what he cares about and
knows with this first Christmas message
he has a much loved and respected act to
follow Rhiannon Mills Sky News
and of course you can watch the King's
first Christmas message right here on
Sky News at three o'clock this afternoon
now also making the news this morning
pele's daughter has shared a photograph
on Instagram of the family who are
spending Christmas day in hospital after
the Brazilian footballers cancer
progressed a medical report earlier this
week showed that the 82 year old now
needed care for cardiac and renal
dysfunction having been treated for
cancer for more than a year
okay let's get a bit more now Christmas
celebrations around the world we're
going to the Middle East now I'm joined
by the Archbishop of Jerusalem
Archbishop hosamina very Merry Christmas
to you Archbishop tell us first of all I
know what a busy day it is for you so
really big thanks to you for taking the
time to speak to us how do you celebrate
Christmas in the cathedral
yeah Merry Christmas to you and to all
our viewers this morning and their
greetings from Jerusalem from the city
of Bethlehem and it is wonderful to be
with you today on this wonderful morning
and the cathedral will celebrate this
morning the the mass for the local
congregation and also some pilgrims but
last night we spent um most of the day
and the night you know in Bethlehem in
the Shepherds field in the Church of the
Nativity and then we ended the evening
with a midnight mass here in Jerusalem
it must be a very special atmosphere in
Bethlehem you mentioned there the
pilgrims of course they haven't been
able to come for a few years are there
many many of them there this year yes
there are quite a few pilgrims not as we
used to have before but the numbers are
picking up and pilgrims are returning to
the land of the Holy One and we're
seeing kind of a pickup in in the the
pilgrimage industry and tourism
tell us a bit uh people will be
interested to know about your Diocese of
course we know what a difficult to say
the least part of the world it is tell
me about the Anglican community in your
diocese yeah so the Anglican dances of
Jerusalem extends into five countries
including Israel Palestine Jordan Syria
and Lebanon we have about 35
institutions between
schools and the clinics and hospitals
and rehabilitation centers and we have
28 congregations scattered throughout
that region and the dances of Jerusalem
is quite vibrant and it's very active
Church in the in the holy land and
especially it is known for its social
and humanitarian Ministry within the
Diocese of Jerusalem of course in
addition to the personal care for our
own people and the witnessing of the
Living Lord
and tell me about some of the pressures
the Archbishop of Canterbury of course
has been talking about the pressures on
Christians in your region how much of
numbers dwindled over the years yeah
absolutely the Christian presence
unfortunately has been on the decline
The Exodus of Christians from the holy
land is a huge concern for the church
leaders and not only in the Holland but
throughout the Middle East but
particularly in Jerusalem itself and the
the holy land at large you know we are
less now than two percent of the total
population comparing it like 100 years
ago we were 27 of the population
Jerusalem alone today is about 6 000
Christians whereas
um 100 years ago we were close to 30 000
patients so it's really great concern
for us to see these numbers dwindling
and especially in this in this land
where Christianity begun where Christ
was born raised died and rose again
and tell me about the political
situation of course the world is
following the the return once again uh
in Israel of uh Benjamin Netanyahu as
prime minister I think for the sixth
time but um the Coalition that he's put
together does that concern you it
involves the far right of course yeah I
think you know like we we as Christians
and the of course and I'm sure that you
know we speak for a quite a good number
here in the holy land and across the
world you know for people who find
moderation as the way forward and the
inclusion and embrace and accepting the
other so if I having a right-wing
government is is a bit concerned for our
communities and especially you know the
rise of some um you know like Tendencies
within the government for more exclusive
more segregation and and more I would
say uh kind of I don't know if some
people can expect in some enmity and
hatred on part of some of the extremists
within the government I hope and that
that this government will bring
stability uh and this is our wish but I
think people are more on the pessimistic
side of things and so we will see what
this government told for the holy land
but
um we have just to wait and see what's
going to happen well artificial we've
been talking there haven't we about some
of the difficulties some Let's uh I'm
afraid we're nearly out of time um let's
end the interview with your your message
of Hope for this Christmas Day
yeah indeed I was just gonna say like
people ask us like are we optimistic in
the holy land and we say that we are
hopeful you know we as Christians are
hopeful for a bright future for this
land for peace and justice for all
people for security for Israel as well
as self-determination for the
Palestinian two-state solution that
people can live in peace of harmony with
each other and Bethlehem and Jerusalem
will continue to be Beacon for peace
life and life
or the message from the cradle of
Christianity there by the Archbishop of
Jerusalem Archbishop ozam very good
talking to you Merry Christmas thank you
very much Merry Christmas to you thank
you now for millions of Americans
festive cheer is being tempered by a
huge winter storm that meteorologists
are calling a bomb Cyclone at least 28
people have died in the storm that
stretch from about 2 000 miles from the
great lakes in the north all the way
down to the border with Mexico
temperatures in some places have dropped
as low as minus 45 and blizzards are
causing some blackouts our U.S
correspondent James Matthews reports
this is what a so-called bomb Cyclone
looks like in time lapse it's timing
could scarcely have been worse
as America mobilizes in the run-up to
Christmas Arctic conditions are blowing
through the country
more than 200 million people are subject
to some form of weather warning
the conditions the blinding snow the
zero visibility
absolute whiteouts it may go down as one
of the worst in history
thousands of flights have been canceled
planes that have taken to the air have
had to negotiate stormy conditions
the winds heavy snow and flooding have
stalled to travel by land too
this was part of a road washed away in
May
and this was the scene on the Ohio
Turnpike where several people died after
50 Vehicles were involved in a collision
one Ohio sheriff ventured onto Twitter
to post a health warning on venturing
outside
we got several areas that are still
impassable
stay home let the plow Crews get their
stuff done deputies worked through the
night with zero visibility and darkness
which made things worse
these conditions are causing problems
with power
tens of millions of people are without
it as the foam Cyclone Battles Through
would-be immigrants stuck on the
southern border and experiencing
temperatures really witnessed there
in the nation's capital Washington DC
members of the public have joined
charities in providing food and clothing
to homeless people
all the help they can get this is no
joke and it's happening all everywhere
these people they still human so-called
hypothermia shelters have been opened
here around the country to libraries and
police stations are doubling as warming
centers as authorities scramble to find
emergency accommodation if you don't
expose yourself to the elements beyond
what you can tolerate you get in a
sleeping bag or under the many blankets
they give away in this park or under a
pile of clothes
but you got to know your limits I know
we're down in the teens but I'm not
looking forward to Sub-Zero
why
um
I value my life
in these particularly cold temperatures
there is concern across the board in
places with power outages and there are
many of them people with roofs over
their head are being advised to seek
shelter not to assume that well that's a
heat Source they will get through the
night
in Maine trees felt by the Christmas
Storms forced onto the road a flock of
turkeys what else what next is the
question here from extreme weather that
has brought extreme challenges James
Matthews Sky News in Washington
well now many of us are of course lucky
enough to be sharing today with family
friends and loved ones but for our Armed
Forces Personnel deployed abroad it is
of course another Christmas away from
loved ones well cult stream guard major
Danny Morrell and Corporal Colin Henry
are both deployed in Somalia from where
they joined me now in a very very Merry
Christmas to you both gentlemen and uh
first of all give us if you would major
morale an overview of just how different
Christmas is in somewhere like Somalia a
lot hotter for a start I'm sure
yes it's about 35 degrees in the shade
with about 80 humidity so it's uh the
weather's a little bit different from
what you've been experiencing in the UK
over the last uh the last couple of
weeks so how do you celebrate Christmas
I mean I presume it is just it's it's
another day on duty with the what a nice
lunch
well yeah it's pretty much business as
uh as usual uh we try to get uh most of
the work done in the morning so we can
uh all enjoy a nice Christmas lunch this
afternoon and then uh maybe watch your
Christmas film and uh definitely watch
the uh The King's Speech later on how we
get on to that uh in a moment or two but
Colin uh tell us I I know you're away
from your family from your your wife and
your son how much contact are you able
to have
uh we're quite lucky out here that
there's a quite a stable internet
connection so I can make a phone call
every day or twice a day and you know I
get to see what he's doing at school and
and what the waitresses and stuff so
luckily out here it's pretty good do you
want to say hello to him how old is he
he's full
and what's his name he's called Killian
he'll be busy in his presence right now
so hey Killian if you can see me
and uh it's your present there as well
you make you make sure that's all sorted
out before you go
a lot of it was left to the white with
uh that's no difference if I was at home
anyway
and uh tell us then about the uh the
Christmas dinner you mentioned 35
degrees there major moral um does does
turkey and Christmas put kind of feel
right or you go ahead anyway
well I think this time of year uh turkey
and Christmas pudding always feels right
no matter where you are
and then you and then you mentioned um
it's gonna be weird isn't it it's going
to be weird for all of us but I suppose
particularly for you as Cold Stream
guards you've um your colonel in Chief
is of course the king and that that
Christmas message you all gather for
that
yes well I mean uh you know it's a
special time of year no matter where you
happen to be serving and uh you know
this year will be uh special it being
the first uh King's Speech uh we'll all
sit down together uh all of us that are
serving currently in Mogadishu and uh
we'll uh we'll look forward to uh to
listen to the king we were you involved
with me of course the Cold Stream guards
were were majorly involved um in the in
the death and the funeral of course of
her majesty the queen what was your
involvement personally major moral
well you know it was uh it was it was a
particularly proud moment to be uh to
take part in the uh the vigil uh and the
laying in state
uh extremely sad uh as it was for
everybody Across the Nation but uh
immensely proud to be uh personally
involved yeah as we all were our view
and Corporal Henry just tell us a bit I
mean a lot of people are going to be
surprised that we're talking to British
forces in in Somalia tell us a bit what
you can of course about the mission
uh so we're mainly here to help
stabilize Somalia so let's not become
she doesn't become a foothold for
terrorist groups such as al-shabab and
to help the Somalian Army stabilize
itself
right and so that involves what training
and support
yeah training mentoring support where we
can yeah
and uh what's morale like then Colonel
Morel on on a day like this because of
course you know separated as we're
discussing from your families but doing
such an important job
David thank you very much for the
promotion but uh yeah I mean uh
it's difficult being away from family at
this time of year uh but it's uh you
know we're all comrades we all uh you
know as do thousands of service people
you know all over the world uh you know
make this selfless commitment to uh to
to join our services but uh you know
it's We're All in This Together We Come
From various different regiments and
units and it's uh you know it's nice to
make new comrades and friends and uh to
spare or to share uh Christmas Day
exactly what Well it can't be long a
major moral and Colin I mean this isn't
your first time away from your family is
it uh as a serving Soldier
no a few years ago I served in the
Falklands on um projects Illinois which
meant that Christmas deployment again
the fault ones gets hot
at Christmas time over there so I'll get
another one one book yeah second one
hopefully my last one away at Christmas
well indeed and when did you get back do
you know when you're getting back to see
Killian and the family
uh I got some r r hopefully at the back
end of uh February March time so I can
see my daughter for her birthday and
then
probably finished to it back into me
okay we can have second Christmas then
that'd be glad to see you both really
good talking to you thank you very very
much indeed and uh the appreciation of
the nation and Merry Christmas to you
both
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
well now the National Trust says that
even though there's an energy crisis Net
Zero targets are more relevant than ever
the trusts invested millions of pounds
in its own green energy Supply and
towards modernizing historical heating
systems in its buildings it's calling
for climate friendly pledges not to be
lost Katarina vitotsi reports imagine
heating a house like this speak Hall in
Liverpool is nearly 500 years old inside
its Victorian heating system was
expensive and difficult to control so
the National Trust which runs the estate
took a leap installing a ground Source
heat pump in a centuries-old property
this isn't a Cellar of the dairy
Courtyard and this is a what we call the
plan true and this is where all the
heart of the ground soil sweet pump
works this is where all the heat drawn
from the field is brought into
originally the house was heated by
liquid petroleum gas boiler well that's
all gone so a fossil fuel free and this
is far more efficient in terms of our
carbon footprint as well as our
reduction in fossil fuels The National
Trust Net Zero Target is 20 30. the
governments is 20 years later both say
heat pumps have a role in
decarbonization speak Hall shows they
are not for new builds I have a juice of
care to look after this special place
forever so by with that ability to
control the levels of heat and humidity
in a way we've never done before is just
one less pressure on looking after the
special place but in a cost of living
crisis Net Zero feels for some not now
that's why reducing consumption is an
important First Step as applicable in a
mansion house as somewhere smaller
the key thing it doesn't really matter
what size the property is or what the
activity the key thing is try and reduce
the amount of energy that you're using
in the first place at home in my
household be doing exactly the same
thing checking I've got that Loft
insulation have I got double glazing can
I even just draw the curtains to um you
know in the evening make sure we're
trying to keep as much heat inside as
possible and then where are you getting
your heat from
um and and can you get that from a more
sustainable um way
tradition meets technology
for a Net Zero future both must work
together Katrina Sky News in Liverpool
now the big question of the day like a
more lothan brussels sprouts are
guaranteed to provoke the age-old debate
around that Christmas table but
regardless of your preference the UK
Remains the biggest Global importer of
the Sprouts well now Rising fuel prices
and a heat wave could change that
appropriately enough then we sent our
Brussels correspondent get it Adam
Parsons to the epicenter of sprout
production it's in the Netherlands
in a muddy Dutch field the reality of a
constant Christmas controversy
hear the slow-moving munching mechanical
caterpillars are relentlessly harvesting
Britain's most divisive vegetable
the Brussels sprout
in the Netherlands the little Sprout is
very big business
Federica is the third generation of her
family to harvest Sprouts this year has
been a tough one
in the summer it was very dry so we need
to irrigate the Sprouts we need to give
fertilizer love to the Sprouts of course
also the costs are quite everything is
expensive labor fertilizer chemicals
everything you need for Sprouts
Britain supermarkets will sell about 750
million Sprouts over Christmas only half
will actually be eaten right here is
where this Brussels sprout starts its
life on a farm in the Netherlands but
now it begins its grueling journey to
you going from field to Fork
thank you
the Sprouts are taken here to a factory
half an hour away it's a Labyrinth of
machines to sort out sprouts
the biggest go to Germany the Dutch like
the small ones and these are the ones
destined for Britain so they
these these British uh what they make
them I think really because they are
fine
not too big not too small I think
they all go through this machine it scan
sprouts for imperfections and Jack is
watching out for any badons it's just
like a puzzle you have to find the the
spray what is not good and then with
this you're gonna play the colors
the Dutch grow more Sprouts than anyone
else they've even changed the taste to
suit British pallets that prefer sweet
over bitter it is a huge effort to tout
the Sprout and despite all that some of
you still won't eat them Adam Parsons
Sky News Holland